tell me what you're enjoying about being
at Wales comic-con today well it's
first time and I'm
of overwhelming to be honest simply by
number of people the extent to which
they're fascinated by the show I mean
it's wonderful the knowledge that they
have of it the fact that so many of them
come with so many they've obviously done
a lot of prep you know they've come with
so many bits and pieces you know whether
it's DVDs or or our box sets or posters
or whatever it's an extraordinary event
and it's kind of weird just sort of
seeing everything that's around us here
feresten is a great character I saw him
season while we see him again in season
three now and as a Kingsguard he's had
to be loyal I feeling away to the kind
of the wrong people husband he's had a
madman a drunk man if he'd have said he
would have had to be in-laws Joffrey's I
wouldn't hey yeah well he actually has
seen in this series that's going out
currently where he says precisely that
that he's you know he understands his
duty as a member of the Kingsguard is to
be loyal to whoever is the ruler but
that he's been unlucky in his choices
and hopefully he's about you know he's
on the cusp of making a better choice
and would like to sort of like serve out
the rest of his days as he says actually
was dignity joining Daenerys I feel is
gonna be a big turning point for him
it's been a great part of the show so
far we've had but about almost midway
through the season what do you feel
about team Daenerys are you up for
fighting for her for that iron throne I
think absolutely I mean I think there's
no question Barristan would not have
traveled the distance he did to find her
unless he was very certain in his own
mind that that was where he wanted to be
and that was who he wanted
to support and be the kind of man he is
I have no doubt that he will be entirely
loyal to her all the way through it'll
be interesting to see what sort of
implications that might have for others
you know but I have no doubt that
Barristan has made a commitment after
all I mean going back in time he was
part of House Targaryen anyway so
there's no question in my mind that he
is faithful to that cause and hopefully
you won't have any awful treatment I'm
sure you won't from Danny like you did
transfer C and Joffrey that was terrible
wasn't it yeah well they're just
impossible those two and you know we
wait to see what happens to both of them
but no no I I have every reason to
believe that life with Daenerys will be
a more positive experience so wait and
see who do you think has what it takes
to come out on top of Game of Thrones do
you think it would be House Stark house
two garyun or House Lannister or another
house you know what's fascinating about
it is that some of the baddies become
goodies and some of the goodies you know
you begin to wonder if they're as good
as they appear so it's not clear cuts
and the writing and they kind of the
sense of uncertainty is brilliant in
that respect I mean who would ever have
thought at the beginning that Ned Stark
was going to get killed you know but the
suspicion of that is the inference seems
to be at the moment that Daenerys will
ultimately you know take over the the
Iron Throne I can't help but feel that
there's a whole story with John Snow
that will somehow or another give him
increased credibility so how exactly
those things come together God knows I
mean at this stage the only one who
knows is probably George and I guess
down and Dave might know you know but I
mean it's it's definitely one that we
can all speculate about but nobody could
be hundred percent sure about you think
Khaleesi do you think Danny would make a
good Queen of the Seven Kingdoms oh yeah
I think she's she's got all the right
strength she's obviously proved out
already she's resilient she's
imaginative she's farsighted she's she's
a kindly ruler she's demonstrated all
those things so far so you can't help
but think that it's a throne deserves a
good king or queen which it does that
she's definitely the right candidate for
you know and Barristan will obviously be
supporting her in that in that course do
you think it takes to survive in the
very cutthroat world of Game of Thrones
probably luck more than anything else be
a good person doesn't nesting to survive
any better than being a bit of a devil
you know luck is probably a large part
to do with its fate
I suppose having the right sort of
support system is key and right now
you've got to say with the Dragons Dany
has the right kind of support system you
know so you know that's another good
reason to be there is the dragons help
keep you safe you know he would you like
to find at the end of Barristan Sword
and live in the game of Thrones you
could have if you got anybody who would
it like to be who what I like to polish
off you mean
you know bizarrely I've never really
stopped to think about that and I know
that some people will be taken care of
by others anyway so that's a hard one to
know
you know truthfully I don't know that I
can answer that not you're free or sassy
me I'd love to see you know I'd love for
something to happen to both of them
absolutely absolute you might know
you're right in that sense in terms of
who does he have most cause to resent
and who would he be most happy to see
disappear absolutely right either at in
fact both of them without any question
they better watch out hey they're
obnoxious to care of them
you know what are they like in real life
baby they're lovely they're lovely
people but they're great at being
obnoxious you know but they are actually
both very very nice people you know and
Jack who plays when he got Joffrey I met
him I didn't expect it to because I
worked with him in season one and then
as it turned ides he had an episode to
do that required him to turn up in
Morocco but we weren't expecting that I
wasn't expected to see him because all
of our stuff was being done in Morocco
necessarily but I wasn't expecting but
some of the king's landing stuff also
ended up being shot there so he turned
up out of the blue so it was nice to see
him again after a couple of years
sir say Lina I haven't seen since series
1 but then that's the weird thing about
this there's so many of us in it that
and people always assume oh but you must
know actually must know what you can
feel you know and never meet people you
know that's just the way it is and I
mean with this it's so big that there
even are different crews so I mean I
work very close to the crew last year
and I will see many of them I'm sure
again this coming year or you know in
fact I had seen many of them previous to
that but you know you don't you don't
really I think the world are there
imagines you all must know each other
and it's extraordinary extent which is
to say you oh yes I worked in that with
X but I never met X you know 3d did me
obviously is a media car then of course
Englanders know what these guys like to
work well in I know from before because
we actually work with something on
something 20 over 20 years ago you know
so I I knew him and had met him Emilia I
met for the first time lovely you know I
have to say one of the great things
about Game of Thrones is that people are
all very decent they're all very easy to
work with everybody wants to try and
basically make it you know a successful
event for for people so there's great
willingness and this great working
together pulling together and you know I
personally have never experienced any
tension you know between people or on
set like a spray and Lord may continue
you know and you mention Morocco as well
what's it like filming over what in a
way you say you have to say it must be
great and in a way it is I mean the
hotels are beautiful you know and the
weather at that time of year is actually
perfect especially for us because it was
this hot it's not too hot but like
anything it has its downside I mean if
you're working in 30-degree weather and
you're wearing sort of like four layers
of leather you know it's gonna be a bit
tiring after a long day in the in the
desert you know and at times it was the
days were long and it was tiring you
know
and the other the only other downside
really is flys flys flys flys everybody
look lies well yeah I mean the Flies are
everywhere and a big problem is food you
know around food and so try to eat your
food and and manage to eat it without
flies pass through you all the time this
is me but that's you know in the scale
of things it's a very small negative you
know you know like what you've been
filming and you found in Belfast as well
in the paint hole somewhere you've
worked before haven't you what was it
like returning them yeah oh well I mean
the paint hole is extraordinary venue I
mean I remember it's not that long ago I
remember when it was first mooted
that it could be a film studio location
you know cos for years it had been
literally where they painted the boats
and I think initially people kind of
thought this doesn't seem realistic and
now of course it's a full grown industry
and in fact there's one new building
purpose-built for filming in addition to
the paint hall and there's another one
on the way because it's expanding you
know so no it's great it's great to have
sort of a filling facility and in fact a
burgeoning film kind of culture if you
like developing on your own doorstep and
it really has I mean over say 10 15
years of the most Belfast has become you
know a sort of a significant film
location when I said Belfast I mean
Northern are as a whole which frankly
before that it would not have been in
fact I remember days when I used to
shoot a lot of stuff about the troubles
in
in the in Belfast say in the 80s they
never shot in Belfast it's too dangerous
so you know you were going to Manchester
or Liverpool or leaves as a look-alike
for Belfast and if you ever did anything
in Belfast you expect especially if it
involved being say in a police uniform
or something like that you wore one of
these yellow kind of jackets off to do
the shot straight back on you know
everything was done to kind of minimize
the possibility of your being perceived
as some sort of target you know so there
was a time when it was very difficult to
film there so sort of freaky that nots
turned around the other way and in fact
filmies frankly know one of the kind of
the economic kind of like Keystone's of
the society you know I mean film is a
significant part this actually Game of
Thrones itself significant part of the
Northern Irish economy know you know
there's so many beautiful places to film
there as well along the coast so 7mm
talking to Jimmy Whelan and he plays you
are a great joy about filming now she's
saying Antrim coast beautiful places
great location sound riposte you know
had some of the most stunning scenery
you could imagine you know it's a
fantastic coast road journey the other
thing about it is that compared with a
lot of places everything's pretty easy
to access you know if you're working in
Belfast that's dead-on if you want to
get out of Belfast to work some
somewhere down the country it's not a
big deal you know the traffic doesn't
make just the planning of a shooting day
problematic I mean you feel them in
London or any major city over here it
can be a hassle but simply because of
traffic you know and airplane noise and
things like that you know I mean we have
those issues obviously but relatively I
think we're quite lucky that way
you know a good place to shoot as an
actor thinking about some good or bad
things a barrister I'm wondering whether
cuz the other kind of mixed time it
doesn't heat with his masters yeah how
would you think you'd fer if you were
Barristan Selmy in real life do you
think you'd be able to survive in his
world yes
and no I probably would not be a
circumspect as Baroness paracin is very
good I think he's very good at being
loyal he's very good at knowing the
place that he has chosen for himself and
being faithful to it why she's prepared
to speak his mind I think he's also you
know pretty careful about not
necessarily ruffling too many feathers I
like to think I'd be the same but every
so often I might be a bit more quick to
say something that I probably should be
saying who knows what does it meant for
you being part of Game of Thrones but
it's so well loved isn't it around the
world what I mean the great thing about
it is that you suddenly you get a
visibility that is bigger than anything
you've ever had before I mean you know
you know I've done a fair bit and I mean
people would recognize you from time to
time but you know I'd be like a lot of
actors where people sort of know the
face but I'm not quite sure of the name
do you know what I mean you know that's
actually that's a very nice position to
be in because you know Fame has probably
as many if not more downsize than it has
upsides you know but with this suddenly
you know you realise that awful lot of
people right there know you you know or
know of you or know of the character at
least he knows you've actually got
people who start to quote follow you you
know and it's kind of weird and it's
nice it's nice as long as it's in
proportion and I'm glad to say in the
context of Barisan is entirely in
proportion you know but it's a sort of
an unusual situation because you know
you're not anticipating it
what happens as I say as long as in
divorce at a very nice experience what
would you like to say to the many fans
of the show who are watching this video
out there keep on watching I'm delighted
that you you know you are watching it
and I hope you carry on enjoying it then
we carry on delivering it to you in a
way that entertains and keeps you keeps
you watching you know so thank you
you